Jimmer Fredette set to join us had the
game against the Rockets the other night
we'll get to that coming up in a moment
the former BYU star now playing for
Shanghai how long is that flight from
Shanghai to from Los Angeles to Shanghai
it's about 11 hours between 11 and 12
hours and what do you do on the plane I
try to I try to sleep for you know
probably four or five hours if I can and
then from there just they have movies
for you i watch my TV shows and you know
listen to you know radio whatever it is
I mean he pretty much just passed the
time however you can so it's a long
flight but you get used to it
what's your go-to TV show what are you
binging on right now I'm watching Friday
Night Lights again I've already I've
already seen it but this is my second
time through and just loving it I love
the show what American shows Iran in
China Oh actual Chinese like an
excellent Chinese like TV none like I
can't get anything that if you actually
have a Chinese cable box I can't get
anything but I have you know what they
call like a VPN so it's like a router
that routes you to the American Internet
and when I use that and then i can use
netflix and i can get you know ESPN I
can get Fox I can get all that stuff but
I have to use these VPN and then from
there it's it's kind of spotty you know
you never know how how good the the
Internet's gonna be or how good the
quality is gonna be so you kind of just
kind of just hit or miss and luckily in
my apartment it's pretty good internet
so you can usually you know watch the
Washington games or watch two whatever
it is that's on at that time but yeah
the Chinese TV actually they have no
they'll have no American American
channels at all you get lonely sometimes
yeah I'm there the whole time with my
family I'm there with you know most of
the time about myself my family will
come out you know for like a month at a
time and they'll be there usually like
twice twice a year and then the rest of
the time I'm there by myself so it can
get lonely for sure I mean that's just
boring sometimes just because you know
when I'm up everyone else is asleep so
it's not like I can just talk to
everybody and you know you know just
call someone and just hang out anyway I
just kind of there so most of the time I
just honestly get out and walk around
the city and kind of explore sharing hi
so I feel like I you know more of a
local there now because I know how to
get everywhere on the subway and and can
navigate everything so I mean it's it's
fun it's a fun time but definitely
there's definitely boring and lonely
parts you know I know what they thought
of Stephon Marbury they build a statue
they're like are you gonna get a statue
are you statue worthy yet in Shanghai I
don't think so yeah I think I'd have to
win a championship first I think if I
want a championship than I think you'd
that would be more of a debate right
there but until until they win a
championship I don't think I'm statue
worthy I mean Steph has got three
championships in Beijing so I mean
that's that was that I was huge for them
because they had won the championship
and forever until he got there many won
three of them so I mean that's why he
got it and he's obviously the biggest
star to ever come out of the CBA over
there and I think I have to win a
championship in order to do that you got
one more year you're left on your
contract with the Shanghai I believe and
then you'll be 30 then what happens here
yes yeah I mean you know I'll be a free
agent after this this summer and you
know I'm I'm looking forward to it you
know I'm looking forward to you know
hopefully having a good successful year
in Shanghai first but then from there
looking forward to kind of exploring my
options
you know I signed a two-year deal last
year so this last offseason I didn't
have any opportunity to go out and kind
of test the market or anything because I
was going back to Shanghai for another
year so this this upcoming offseason I'm
looking forward to testing the waters
and seeing what's out there obviously if
there's an NBA team that that wants me
and wants me to be a part of their
organization I'd love to be able to do
that you know so we'll see see what
happens but I feel like I'm in a really
good place in my career right now I'm
comfortable with how I'm playing and how
I am as a as a basketball player and I
feel like you know wherever I'm going to
play when I get enough
I'm going to be able to succeed and
though I'm excited to see what happens
this offseason
he's Jimmer for dad joining us after
putting up for t-shirt you put up 40
shots against the Rockets alright very
light did you did you know that you had
40 shots you shot more than harden did
no I did not know that I mean I knew
that I saw it quite a bit you know I was
out there playing aggressively obviously
I played the whole game and you know you
know it's difficult you know with the
Rockets specifically with the way they
play defense because they just switch
everything so we were running our plays
you know I mean and they just switched
everything and that everybody's like
well that didn't work so what are we
supposed to do now and so I just tried
to get the ball and tried to be really
aggressive try to make something happen
a lot of times off of the dribble and I
one-on-one situation or whatever and
just trying to be aggressive and you
know obviously put up a lot of shots but
you know it's a fun way to play
basketball for sure oh yeah man I'm so
envious they had the green light
what did harden say to you I said just
keep working because I'd keep working
you know and you're yeah I think he
respects my game and obviously I respect
his game he's an unbelievable basketball
player that VP had a great season last
year and you know so I'm excited to see
how they do this year as far as coming
back from the year that they had last
year but I think they're motivated and
playing hard but ya know we just you
know exchanged pleasantries real quick
and everything and then we're on the
basketball whose game
who are you similar to that who's having
success I know that we want to say
you're steph curry but i mean that's
you're not steph curry but it doesn't
mean that you don't have a place in the
league that's what i'm just trying to
figure out what is missing here yeah for
sure
you know i don't know specifically like
a player that i just like see myself
modeling modeling my game after are who
i compared with completely but when i
see myself as a role in the NBA if that
was the case to get back in is that
would be a guy that would be you know a
guy off of the bench that can come in
and just you know light it up
you know i mean be able to come in and
and score the bass
a ball and be able to be a guy that's a
you know a six-man type Jamal Crawford
type you know come in and be able to
just go and score the basketball and at
a high level and hopefully you know
effectively I didn't not out I think
that's something that you know I could
bring to a team I can come in and really
score and shoot the basketball be
aggressive and you know be able to play
you know hopefully you know somewhere
around fifteen twenty minutes and be
able to really you know help a team if
they're you know if they're not doing
well or they need a spark off the bench
I feel like I'm a guy that I could come
in and really help with that and any
type of scoring or shooting punch that a
team would need so that's kind of how I
see myself being able to have that type
of role in the NBA and I know that I can
do that with the right opportunity but
you know that's that's kind of what I
see well enjoy the flight back if if
that's a possibility of enjoying the
flight back but you know what good luck
over there we'll check in with you and
you know hopefully there's still a
chance in the NBA there for you Jimmer
yeah I think there will be hopefully
after this season but I appreciate the
support band and I love listening to you
guys and thanks for sending over the
t-shirts your brother sent some t-shirts
to us hi bud thank you talk to you soon
thank you later
thanks yeah for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]